نقلت صحيفه يديعوت احرونوت عن جادي
ايزنكوت رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
السابق والوزير بمجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
نقلت عنه قوله ان سلوك الحكومه
الاسرائيليه قبل السابع من اكتوبر وبعده
يتسم بالفشل بشكل كبير جدا واضاف ان كل من
كان في منصب عسكري وسياسي يوم السابع من
اكتوبر وقبله بعشر سنوات يتحمل مسؤوليه
واضحه واضاف ايزنكوت ان نتنياهو يتحمل
المسؤوليه وان القياده الاسرائيليه لا
تقول الحقيقه للشعب من جهتها نقلت نيويورك
تايمز عن ايزنكوت قوله ان اسرائيل لم تسقط
حماس وان اهداف الحرب لم تتحقق بعد مشيرا
الى ان التوصل الى اتفاق مع حماس هو
السبيل الوحيد لاطلاق سراح الرهائن واكد
انه كان يجب بذل كل الجهود للحفاظ على وقف
اطلاق النار المؤقت في نوفمبر الماضي
واعتبر ايزنكوت ان وجوده في حكومه الطوارئ
حال دون نشوب ح شامله مع حزب الله ما كان
سيمثل خطا استراتيجيا فادحا حسب
تعبيره